welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of house of
the dragon episode 3 which shows how you
can win over any cookout by serving up
pork or crab and thanks for your
patience on this one i don't get
advanced screeners for the show and we
don't want to force anyone to work on a
holiday but here it is my scene-by-scene
analysis of all the visual details and
deeper layers of meaning you might have
missed in this episode now last week
when i went frame by frame through those
opening credits i promised that i would
be laser focused on the opening titles
in case anything got updated and yep
there was one sneaky change last week
the bloodline on the greenhouse
hightower side of everything flowed from
otto his dial marked with the hand of
the king icon to alicent marked with the
old town beacon icon and then stopped
there but now the bloodline flows from
alicent and meets viserys's bloodline
marking the birth of a new possible air
young aegon as the camera pans down you
can see another dial waiting for aegon
but for now it is still untouched by the
blood because he has not yet been named
the heir the opening image of the
episode shows the sigil of house
valerian the sea horse on a burning sail
as the triarchy ravages the valerian
fleet this sea horse is not the seahorse
fish that we know it's a rearing
mammalian horse with the lower half of a
fish and bins that resemble wings
together with the embers this
foreshadows the true savior of this
episode's closing the fire of a flying
valerian dragon sea smoke even its name
parallels what we are currently seeing
in its opening smoke on the sea and
speaking of ash and ruin epic hero merch
has a new shirt inspired by house of the
dragon called ash and ruin and you can
get it at epicheroshop.com the valerian
knight screams that craig is drehar the
crab theater the sea snake will have
your foxy again by poxy effingham head
he was referring to the fact that gragas
has grayscale which you could see on his
face in his shoulders last episode
hiding under his golden mask which is
also the mask of the sons of the harpy
those are the assassins who threatened
daenerys rule over meereen in game of
thrones season 5. now these game of
thrones winks are new to the character
in this series presumably drehar
acquired his harpy mask from piracy in
the free cities and if you remember in
game of thrones the men in the ruins of
valyria had greyscale which does make
kragus in a way doubly representative of
the rot that infests the targaryen's
ancestral home and a future threat of
the ambitions of their descendant
daenerys this four valerian night hails
the arrival of prince daemon and his
dragon caraxies
they even vfx the night spewing up blood
and based on the length of its tail as
it swipes out the bonfire to the right
it probably also swept away that guy's
corpse say damon's bravery has nothing
to do with the good of the realm it's
all about his pride the crab feeder and
his men hide in their caves and this is
exactly how the dornish managed to stave
off the targaryen dragons during the
failed conquest of dorne also the fact
that they took out aegon's sister white
rainey cinder dragon miraxis with a
scorpion weapon definitely helped as
well now as we fade in on the king's
feasts the first words we hear are those
of young aegon
[Music]
and what's for dinner pork we're
shadowing the game-changing game that
will be brought in during the hunt now
notice how the nobles say he has your
hair your grace
he does have my hand he has your eyes
your grace yes he does
and you have my nose and baby aegon
pulls away from viserys's hand because
notice how throughout the scene and
throughout this episode viserys has now
lost two of his fingers on his left hand
it's like with every episode a new piece
of this guy is dropping off and as
always the valerian steel dagger of egg
on the conqueror which yes again plays a
huge role throughout game of thrones
continues to jut into frame which is
especially ironic now since his
withering left hand would be the one to
draw that dagger pretty soon all that's
gonna be able to grab it is a stump it's
just a separate year of his rule renders
him less and less worthy to carry
aegon's legacy represented by that
dagger also yes i have to point this out
the frame that we cut to aegon that kid
is totally looking at the camera these
child actors they always see us otto
hightower speaks with his older brother
hobert lord of old town who actually saw
him swearing fealty to renera in episode
1 which makes his assumption that aegon
would be named new heir pretty brazen
he's the king's firstborn son i don't
know that his grace sees it so clearly
then it lies with you to make him see it
us we see how otto pressuring his
daughter allison to influence the king
is really a trait passed down to him
from his hightower elder thailand
lannister is the new master of ships
replacing corliss who resigned last
episode known as his lannister lion
thailand and his twin brother jason
lannister are both played by actor
jefferson hall who played sir hugh with
the vale in season one of game of
thrones i love how he plays thailand as
a worrywart and jason has a proud
braggart shots later in this episode
actually winklevoss him in twice side by
side but there's a fun edit out of this
scene can someone tell me
where in the seven halves ronera might
be
under
the
dragon's eye
yeah the jump cut to the barred song
answers the king's question with an
answer he might not like his daughter
rhaenyra is under the dragon's eye as if
she might be the destin descendant in
aegon's song of ice and fire dream
additionally rene is in the godswood
beneath the red leaves of the weirwood
tree anointing our destiny from the old
gods as well the divine forces in
westeros that pre-date the targaryens
which plays a key symbolic role later
now this bard's song is about nymeria
and her 10 000 ships the historical
warrior queen who was referenced in the
same location episode one you can
actually see the name nymeria when the
page turns at the top of that paragraph
so either anira had this book mended to
replace the page that she tore out or
she could be reading a new book about
this person if you think about it would
likely be the only woman in her life
that she now feels companionship with
and by the way hbo is developing a
nymeria 10 000 ship spin-off series so
you know the show is just trying to
accept nymeria in our brains oh you won
a 10 000 ship's show now well we got one
for you now this singer is named samwell
like samwell tarly who in game of
thrones coins a title a song of ice and
fire for his history of these recent
conflicts which is ironic that he would
pick the same phrase aegon the conqueror
used to describe the dream of white
walkers but the fact that we focus on
this bard so much in the scene like him
stretching his sore hand makes me wonder
if this could actually be the show's
version of the character mushroom the
mummer in bayern blood who provided the
salacious details of the subjective
historical account that george r martin
intended fire and blood to be naming him
samwell could be a nod to that meta
aspect of an in-universe character later
playing a role in documenting the
history of it now the castle walls
torches are held by dragon mouths so
that the torch's wind lit would look
like a dragon breathing fire i love that
touch or tasteful decor than the literal
bestiality porn on every other surface
of this castle whereas before these two
young women laid together beneath this
tree even the actresses admitted that
they were doing so with an intentional
flirty undertone now rainier will not
even look at the queen yet the blocking
suggests she's using the eyes of the
face in the weirwood tree trunk as the
eyes in the back of her head in a way
alison is under the dragon's eye viserys
and allison encourage raniere to bear
children it's not so bad
the days are long but aegon came quickly
and without fuss yeah those nurses got
some tea clearly aegon's birth was rough
for this teenage bride and like many
queens in the middle ages especially
ones now focused on popping out the next
kid she doesn't really get to spend much
time mothering her toddler young aegon
looks at camera again and pushes that
dragon figurine on the floor we'll screw
like children when they've been
slaughtered
your gracie also has your love of
dropping dragon toys yes in this episode
ranira goes from hating the sound of a
screaming board the editing of her line
there sinking with aegon shouts to at
the end of this episode stabbing a
screaming boar i wonder who ronero was
visualizing stabbing there as they
arrive at the hunting camp we see the
red keep in the background of the shot
compared to the game of thrones season 1
scenes that take place in the kingswood
i just love the visual context we get
here to anchor us in the setting and
nice when your tv show's got bigger
budget master of laws lionel strong
applauds their arrival flanked by his
two sons larry strong with a club foot
and his brother sir harwin breakbone
strong who's going to be an important
character throughout the series hovert
hightower declares
[Applause]
second of his name is the title of this
episode if her hobart shouted here in
front of everyone is a huge breach of
protocol as aegon would not be called
aegon ii aka second of his name until
the king officially names him an heir
which he has not done yet despite the
patriarchal customs of this society
rhaenyra remains the proclaimed heir
whom again hobart swore fealty too so
that conflict of whether aegon should be
the second of his name is at the heart
of this episode and while it is his
birthday that they're celebrating really
this episode is the name day for other
targaryens each of them enter this world
in a new way by the episode's end
baptized in fire and blood as ramirez
walks into the red tent we see her new
hair braid at the back of her head which
matches the interlocking circles of the
valerian steel necklace that damon gave
her this one always got eyes on the back
of her head ronero walks in on kiera
lannister dropping some exposition
when one of lord swans ships sailed
through the stepstones what will happen
to lady joan
she's to be sold to a pillow house in
the free cities if you believe the
rumors joanna swann was kidnapped and
sold into sexual slavery in lease but in
the text becomes a beloved citizen named
the black swan and essentially rules the
city of elise so don't worry joanna's
gonna be fine
lady jocelyn redwine gets shut down by
ronira now have you served the one with
late lady red wine by eating cake
now actually before elena tyrell our
heroine from game of thrones married
into the tyrell family she actually came
from house redwine so this dog-loving
woman is her distant ancestor jason
lannister puts the moves of rhaenyra by
bragging about casterly rock the rock is
thrice the height of the high tower in
old town taller still than the wall in
the north yeah it's fitting that jason
would brag about how tall the castle is
when famously casterly rock's best
features are really the tunnels and
mines within the rock that not many
people know about as tall as the castle
is vernier could always fly higher than
it on cyrax which jason even knows that
she did because raniere visited casterly
rock with her mom as a girl i just bring
this up to compare jason to another
boastful character like damon a guy
whose greatest strength so far in the
series has been his knowledge of the
secret tunnels and passageways hidden
within the castle beneath the surface
and i love how when jason first
approached ronira raniere is framed in
the raging bonfire behind her fire has
always been a symbol of strength for the
targaryen family and it's almost like
rene is able to brush off jason because
she is fueled by this fire fire that she
doesn't yet let explode out of her now
those targaryens are not only known for
their platinum hair but how about that
smooth smooth skin no dark under eye
circles or blemishes on any of them now
they have the maesters to thank for
their good skin but for the rest of us
there's geology geology is a 13-time
award-winning skincare company that
creates simple effective personalized
skincare products you got your everyday
face wash you're repairing night cream
your vital morning face cream and your
nourishing eye cream just click the link
in the description and take a 30 second
quiz tell geology about your skin and
their team of dermatologists will design
a regimen just for you it ships direct
to your door their products are great
for acne wrinkles or any other skin
concerns you'll be sent a 30 day trial
so whether you're getting wind burned
from riding dragons or just look a
little tired from staying up late
breaking down the house of the dragon
episodes you'll have a plan for looking
good just the simplicity of it all is my
favorite part they're ramping up to
release brand new hair care products
like all new co-wash shampoo and
conditioner be sure to let them know
that you're interested when you fill out
the diagnostics so you can be the first
to know when it releases they're
offering a crazy deal right now you get
70 off on their 30-day five-piece trial
kit head to geology.com to get 70 off
your 30-day trial when you use the code
rockstars70 or just click the link below
that's geology.com promo code
rockstars70 to save 70 off your 30-day
trial otto breaks up viserys and
raniere's fight with the royal huntsman
are sent to report your grace has been a
sighting of a white heart the stag is
the king of the king's wood your grace a
regal portent for prince aegon's name
day yes the white stag is a creature of
legend in the king's wood that was
actually the same stag that robert
baratheon was pursuing on his fateful
hunt in a game of thrones sir howland
sharpe later tells the king
before the dragons roared over westeros
white heart was the symbol of royalty in
these lands
i've never been one for signs of
importance your grace but if the gods
did wish to show their favor
so for viserys this stag represents one
symbol of fate grounded in nature
something real as opposed to his
unreliable dragon dreams it's a sign of
power that preceded aegon's conquest
that still eludes this targaryen king
during their time together sir kristin
tells ranira about his name being added
to the white book you remember that's
the book containing the hall of famer
kingsguard knights that we saw in the
game of thrones series jason lannister
gives viserys a golden spear a lannister
weapon to kill a stag the symbol of
house baratheon obviously some symbolic
parallels there with the future
lannister treachery against king robert
on his hunt otto suggests ronira mary
young aegon ugh while llamo strong
smartly suggests leonor velaryon
lionel's pick would heal the division
with the valerions the wealthiest house
while otto's pick would prevent a future
succession crisis in civil war perhaps
lionel just sees that crisis as
inevitable and wants valerian closer to
the crown rather than having them on the
outside looking in a boar attacks sir
kristen and rhaenyra which we know
rulers should be worried about and of
course it was a boar that fatally
wounded robert baratheon but rhaenyra
stabs this board of death she's unafraid
of its childlike squeals and she coats
herself in blood the fire that was
gradually building bernard throughout
this episode finally explodes and takes
the form of blood and so through fire
and blood her true self emerges we cut
directly from this to the shot of
viserys by the campfire with the flames
crackling in the foreground as if he's
trying to draw strength from these
flames but without getting a single drop
of blood on him this episode he feels
powerless many in my line being dragon
riders
very few among us have been dreamers
what is the power of a dragon
it's the path of prophecy ah so we see
how vasara sees the distinction between
dragon riders and dreamers dragon riders
like damon and rhaenyra act brashly and
overwhelm their enemies with shock and
awe whereas dreamers are more cautious
they use their belief in prophecy to try
to stay a step ahead for viserys it
wasn't aegon's conquest that inspired
him it was aegon's dream and before that
dennis's dream that saved his family
from the doom of valeria bezary saw more
power in those dreams and fashioned
himself a dreamer but now he's beginning
to doubt himself because as he shares
with allison his dream of a son wearing
aegon's crown the dream that he told
emma about he now admits that he only
dreamt that image one time and he could
never again will it into a recurring
prophecy style dream it's interesting to
note that viserys's dream showed aegon
wearing the conqueror's crown not the
crown he is currently wearing the crown
worn in the series by viserys and its
predecessor jiharis which are seen on
their dials in the opening credits that
is not aegon's crown aegon's crown is a
circulate of valerian steel with square
cut rubies in it that crown encircles
the dial that represents egg on the
cronker that starts off the opening
credits and was last worn by megor the
crew without spoiling anything aegon the
conqueror's ruby crown does come back in
this narrative but for now viserys
thought naming renera error was his way
of quitting that whole dream obsession
but now with aegon's birth his dream is
actually coming true again and now this
white heart legend is supporting that
destiny he doesn't know which signs to
heed so it actually comes to a bit of
relief to viserys when breakbone strong
has trapped a different normal stag may
not be white nor grace
i think it's a big lad
uses the lannister spear to stab the
stag but he misses the mark and requires
a repeated jab it's actually pretty
pathetic a contrast to renera and sir
kristen who based a beast without any
help and killed it a lot faster the way
viserys puts down this dag it's almost
like he's putting himself down also i
love this detail notice his left ring
and pinking finger are lifted in his
glove because those fingers have rotted
off and those parts of the glove are
empty so when your fingers aren't
filling the glove it just kind of sticks
outward i love this detail because the
actor patty constantine had to
consciously act it with his fingers out
to imply empty glove fingers just to
show attention to detail appreciated by
only the folks who break these down on
youtube renera looks down over the
kingswood camp and in this same unbroken
shot of her gliding over at all the
camera pants over to reveal the
legendary white heart presenting itself
to her
[Music]
yes the white whale that eluded both her
king father and will elude robert
baratheon in the future appears to this
targaryen heir who is anointed in blood
the fact that rhaenyra spares it though
is interesting because you could totally
imagine her descendant daenerys slaying
that white heart and proudly dragging it
back into camp to show off her power but
this move by renera can be seen as a
gesture of restraint or compassion but i
see it as a heedlessly contrarian
refusal to play the games of her father
and his men she's literally over all of
them so by letting this white heart flee
she leaves it as a secret known only to
her while to her father it remains a man
in mystery that he'll never know whether
or not it was even real all her father
has now are his [ __ ] dragon dreams
but renewal knows as a secret in her own
heart that she had a physical sign from
nature that her claim to the crown is
destined and i cannot help but see a
parallel with another queen in a stag
the climax of the 2006 film the queen
with helen mirren as queen elizabeth ii
shooing away a long sought-after stag
during a hunt to mirror her softening
compassion for princess diana renera
instead returns with a victory that was
all her own and pork is on the menu
unlike her father rhaenyra is covered in
blood proving to all these lords
watching that her kill was not
ceremonial she earned it i love how
particularly breakbone strong gives her
a huge grin as he skins that rabbit otto
tells allison that aegon should become
air over rhaenyra the road ahead is
uncertain but the end is clear
aegon will be king i'd love this as a
meta line for this whole prequel series
like you can look at a family tree and
know where this ends i mean even if
you've seen game of thrones you know
where it ends but it's really the
uncertain road ahead the snaking
bloodlines that branch and how they
flood stuff that's gonna make this
interesting to watch onto the stepstones
there is a 52-second shot showing three
valyrian ships and damon's dragon
caraxies in a battle against the
treasury forces one of those fireballs
hits the center of a ship and sinks it
another fireball appears to go through
the gap in the sails of the leftmost
ship so it's really by luck that it was
able to escape that corliss says
we must press the attack continue
sending the dragons yes he said dragons
a little signal that during all this
time they definitely had more than one
dragon at their disposal they had
caraxies and leonor's dragon sea smoke
so it's not like c smoke came out of
nowhere corliss debate strategy with his
son leonor remember he was the younger
kid of the tourney with his sister
lyanna in episode 1. he's also talking
with corliss's brother damond he's the
one who sent the notice to the crown no
southern map board uses crab claws for
kragus's forces as well as fish jawbones
and other fish figurines but when lenore
suggests an offering of flesh to draw
out craig is from the caves damon
arrives in that moment and plops his
dragon designed helmet on the table even
though he hasn't made this decision yet
he is going to end up volunteering
himself as the bait and his helmet in
this moment serves as his figurine
putting himself on the game board damon
reads the king's letter and then pummels
the messenger adam and later we hear
vazaris's voice over reading it as damon
rose alone toward the shore so we
realized that the only thing stopping
him from doing this until now was just
his pride he's only moving on to this
last resort tactic because his brother's
about to steal the victory from him as
viserys even said damon would sooner die
than let that happen and he's about to
risk doing that and i love this shot of
damon rowing out from behind burning
ship wreckage making it look as though
he is emerging from the fire just
another example of a targaryen this
episode of being anointed from fire and
blood now damon appears to surrender and
cragus watches them with only one eye
since that other eye has been rotted by
the grayscale maybe that's why he had
trouble seeing sea smoke and all that
smoke and fog because he didn't forget
he was searching the sky for those
dragons it's just this dragon had a
convenient color tone to it damon cuts
through the triarchy men with a sword
dark sister but eventually his plot
armor runs out and he gets tripped up by
one soldier and then plugged with a
bunch of arrows when he's pinned we
actually get a few extreme close-ups of
dark sister's hilt you can see how the
crossguard forum's outstretched dragon
wings i love all the little production
design details of the show as the screen
fills with more and more smoke and fog
it masks the reveal of sea smoke
leonor's dragon colored silver gray and
releasing a roar that's actually pretty
unlike the roars of psyrex and crazies
[Music]
now leonardo remember is the son of the
targaryen queen who never was rhaenys
and since she's a dragon rider her kids
are dragon riders now sea smoke as a
dragon is a bit younger and is more
targeted with its attacks notice how it
breathes a perfect u-shape around daemon
but doesn't torch him in particular
whereas karaxi's just stomped a friendly
earlier sea smoke even grabs four
charges fighters from a melee mess
including both sides and manages to
avoid grabbing any of their own men it's
kind of like blind reaching a bag of
starbursts and pulling out four pinks
what are the odds of that and damon
emerges from the cave with the top half
of kragus's torso hopefully grabbing
part of the skin that didn't have
greyscale on it but like his niece
renera he is fully covered in blood of
his hunted game earning the loyalty and
respect of all in sight both damon and
roniro without any help from the king
have brought home the bacon and scored
victories through fire and blood but i
will leave you with my favorite detail
from this entire final sequence that
takes up 12 and a half minutes at the
end of the episode throughout all of
this matt smith never utters a single
word of dialogue all of his emotions he
conveys through his face and his
physicality in fact the last line that
he spoke in this episode was in the
opening scene when he called out craigs
from the caves it's almost like he was
letting that reverberate until the man
was able to accomplish his task thank
you so much for watching these analyses
i really try to dig into the visual
details and symbolism so for all of you
so patient and willing to wait a day or
two longer please please please do me a
favor and share these videos with
everyone you know who watches house of
the dragon i'm really just trying to
enhance everyone's viewing experience
and again thank you for joining me every
week as we do that you can follow me on
tik tok instagram and twitter avos
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you